our series pushing the limit shares
stories of ordinary people who are
accomplishing incredible feats and
incredible is a word here this morning
we're going to introduce you to alyssa
bachner remember her name along with
their horse milo
they became one of the most
inspirational riding teams in the world
of show jumping lead national
correspondent that's david bagno who
knows he knows how to ride too shows us
how they did it while overcoming
impossible odds
have you ever seen someone on the back
of a 1200 pound horse jump a fence
well watch again
because lissa bachner is doing it blind
i do not see this fence at all
until right now
how much is getting to a jump and
getting over it dependent on the horse
taking you there
98
wow her left eye is a prosthetic as for
the right eye what exactly can you see
where i see my finger when it gets here
and then it disappears at here you see a
little bit of light but again it's
blurry
you can't make out quite what it is
right you can see color
i see color very well
the minute i see that white fence with
flowers and the green
i know i need my outside leg
she invited us to her farm in wellington
florida
where she even gave me a chance to ride
with her when did you start riding when
i was three
she grew up at an equestrian center in
virginia that her mother owned she's
been a champion rider since the age of
five when she was diagnosed with uveitis
that's a rare inflammatory eye disease
and it made school difficult
was childhood lonely for you
no i had horses
it was her mother who encouraged her to
follow her passion and ride
everything good in my life is because of
my mother
my mother
knew as much as she wanted to keep me at
home and keep me safe
she bought me a horse
bachner never doubted herself but her
fellow competitors did
they were making fun of
my riding that i should stop i remember
looking away from them because i was
crying
and i remember thinking
i am going to kick your ass the next
time
i get in that ring that was when i was
determined to figure out how to do it
and better than anyone else
enter milo an inexperienced horse that
bochner's trainer found in europe this
horse walked off the trailer
and i looked at it and went yeah
and i
looked at this
emaciated
mangy creature milo needed somebody to
believe in him and bachner did
not only did milo carry her over jumps
he guided her through the countless
mental and emotional obstacles as they
traveled the country together competing
and winning
where was milo ranked in the country
with you in
2004 uh we won the country i get the
chills just so do you say that well not
only that now i've got the chills
so we were so in tune with each other
and we went for three months where we
didn't lose a class the pair's
extraordinary bond is told in her book
milo's eyes
while she was at the top of her game she
says she misunderstood a conversation
between her mother and stepfather that
led her to think the competitions were
costing too much money so bachner
suddenly sold milo i thought i was
bleeding everyone dry i wasn't
contributing it was a lot of money in
hindsight the decision to sell him was
the worst decision of my life because
you'd lost more than a champion you lost
i had lost my best friend i had lost my
savior but three and a half years later
and i very quietly
said
milo really and if horses could cry
i could feel his body heaving and of
course i was a mess and i walked down
i said i don't understand and my mom
said i bought milo back for you i found
him and i bought him back for you
and i looked at her and i said
he's mine again and she said he's always
been yours
together again milo carried bachner to
one more victory we walked in the ring
and they announced us the entire
coliseum went silent
and
hearing our name together
and so
three classes
100 people in each class
won every single one you did
on this horse that was now 16
almost 17 years old
that was their last hurrah
before milo died at the age of 17. i
knew the moment he was gone because i
felt him go through me it was awful
nothing will replace milo left here but
lissa may have found her next best
partner this is a magnetic owned and
shown by melissa
now with less than five percent of her
eyesight remaining she's putting her
trust in a new horse
she calls mango
good job
last month we were there she and mango
won first in their class at the world
equestrian center in ocala florida now
49 years old lissa bachner is riding
and she's writing with the intention of
helping others to the people who will
watch this and say oh my gosh i'm
inspired by this woman what would you
say i would tell them i knew myself well
enough that to know that i could not
exist without the horses
and that i had to find a way to continue
to ride there are people who don't give
up and don't take no for an answer and i
did not do it myself i had a lot of help
and i have no shame in saying that i
asked for help and i got it
okay david this is
my type of girl
two things one you look good on a horse
yeah um
is she competing against other writers
who
are blind nope able-bodied folks like
you and i wow i wasn't expecting to hear
milo died yeah so that threw me a little
had a wonderful life though yeah yeah
listen as a rider i said to her i can't
imagine riding up to a jump and seeing
the distance blind and she goes i can't
imagine doing it to where i could see
wow i was like
david thank you so much i love her
confidence